je m'appelle m'élever nord gidza est
plus mon plus jeune âge j'ai chéri le
rêve de devenir médecin
j'espère de tout mon coeur devenir
neurologue dans la présentation le
trouble neurologique nommé tdah sera
démystifier le trouble du déficit de
l'attention avec de l'hyperactivité est
un sujet pour lequel j'ai dû effectuer
plusieurs recherches
vous savez il ya des problèmes
neurologiques qui nous questionnent
beaucoup comme le tdah maintenant être
que vous ou quelqu'un d'autre de votre
famille en est atteint mon but
aujourd'hui c'est de vous faire
comprendre qu est ce que c est 10 h
c'est quoi le tdah
le tdah est un trouble neurologique
les personnes qui en sont atteints et
prouve la difficulté à contrôler leur
comportement généralement diagnostiquée
à étapes de l'enfance ce trouble
continue très souvent à se manifester
alors aux jeunes les enfants les
adolescents et les adultes peuvent être
atteints de tdah l'abréviation pub et à
achever du trouble déficitaire de
l'attention avec hyperactivité
quelles sont les conséquences du tdah al
enfants atteints de tdah peu à bout au
comportement différent celui de ses
frères soeurs ou amis il y possède qu
ils oublient de faire des choses ou
qu'on doit vous rappeler constamment
surtout lorsque c'est quelque chose dans
lieux c'est ce qu'on appelle de
l'inattention
parfois il se sent excité avec beaucoup
d'énergie
c'est ce qu'on appelle de
l'hyperactivité parfois il peut alors
répondre aux questions avant même qu'on
ait fini de les poser exemple il très
bien sa vie avant que le feu passe moi
existe il des médicaments contre ça eh
bien oui
la médecine a beaucoup évolué le médecin
commencera probablement pas prescrits en
a fait le don de stimulants mais
augmentera graduellement jusqu'à un
effet ce produit
s'ils sont les symptômes ne s'améliore
pas après l'essai de moindres ou au type
de médicaments le médecin voudra
probablement le réévaluer il est
possible qu'ils soient atteintes
d'affections autre que le débit h
ophélie j'espère qu'on savait maintenant
plus le tdah
mais ici vous en être atteint mais deux
personnes peut vous aider comme pepsico
le neuropsychologue et plein d'autres
mais les pertes mais à tous les enfants
qui me regarde en ce moment et qui en
sont atteints sachez que les personnes
les mieux placées pour vous aider sans
vous par an et n'ayez pas peur d'en
parler car vous êtes gay qui vous êtes
comme vous